[Music]
all right it's one question friday where
we answer one question from one of the
listeners if you want to submit your
question go to mfmpod is it dot com
and click the little microphone to
submit your question this one came in
through text message somebody said
hey uh hey dude i'm giving a my first
talk at a conference i got invited to
speak at this conference i'm giving my
first talk uh i'm excited about it but a
little bit nervous like he's like i know
it's gonna be fine but i just don't want
it to be lame he's like you and sam are
really good at doing these kind of
public speaking things
you know
what's the trick you know what do i do
to make this good uh what do i do to
make this not just the same old same old
so i thought we would give maybe
our take on what we do to make public
speaking fun slash interesting um what
do you got
well i would say first public speaking
is a skill so a lot of people think well
i speak all the time and i speak in
public therefore i'm probably going to
be decent at public speaking it doesn't
really work that way so public speaking
some people are talented and they are
just better gary vaynerchuk's like that
i think he's just better than everyone
else
but for most people it's a skill so i
highly recommend like reading a book on
it or like googling like how to be
better at this it's a skill set and so
there are tricks i don't think that this
is like the best time for us just to say
like what all the tactics are but a few
of them are just like on storytelling
and it's very similar to stand-up comedy
which again some people are just born
better but a lot of people you just have
to learn and try and so buy a book on it
and i think that's actually the easiest
first step
is there a book you'd recommend on it or
just not the top of your head
yeah i think what's the one that you and
i were reading on storytelling uh by the
guy who like won all the muse to come
story worthy i think yeah i think soy
worthy was awesome that i had a bunch of
takeaways from that and then speak like
a ted talk or something like that it's
called like the ted talker ted talk
speakers guide or something like that
that's quite good but the story worthy i
actually thought was pretty phenomenal
so i'm gonna tell you what i told him i
said um
uh and by the way he had also said he's
like i wanna bring that showmanship that
you guys talked about so they think he's
picking up on on what we talked about so
i said all right three things
i said number one
um
be in peak state it's very easy when
you're nervous to go kind of like inward
you're kind of low energy your mouth's a
little dry your shoulders hunched over
um like fundamentally as soon as you
walk out there people are gonna read
your body language they're gonna read
your energy and they'll start to respond
to it when somebody comes out and
they're electric you can feel that
they're excited that they got a like a
bounce in their step you're paying
attention because you want to know what
they're all about i said so just make
sure before you go out there
do some push-ups go run a wind sprint do
some jumping jacks do whatever you got
to do physically to literally just get
blood flowing and be in a like more
uh like high performance state i said
think about it athlete doesn't go on the
field until they are warmed up until
they're ready a singer or a dancer a
performer they're not going to go on the
stage until they're warmed up and
they're feeling loose and warm
it's the same thing if you're going to
go talk you want to feel loose and warm
both in your voice but also your body so
that's the first thing just do the
physical get the physical part right
the second is remember
this is this is the first of many you'll
do this 500 more times so this might
feel like a big deal now but a year from
now this will be an afterthought you'll
just you won't even really remember how
it went um just treat it as a practice
rep one of 500 times you're going to do
this it's a chance to experiment with
some things that'll depressurize this
moment for you and it'll
teach you to remember that like this is
just like you said it's a skill you got
to get good at it to get good at any
skill you need practice reps i said the
last one i said storytelling i said
have a back pocket story right so what's
a backpacker story it's like you started
the podcast uh that we just recorded
with the um
dude i gotta tell you this funny story
on you know there's something that
happened to me today before we do this
i was walking through the park and these
nannies were getting attacked with this
guy and i'm they're in my fanny pack and
me and the fanny and the nannies we all
fought these guys off basically it's
like this funny story and it doesn't
need to be
a hilarious extreme story like that it
could be anything it could be like let's
say you're at a conference
um you might be like
you know before we start i just talked
to this guy in the back and he asked me
a really interesting question i want to
ask you guys this too because
i honestly i think we might be really
split on how we answer this question
already you really want to know what it
is and i've taken control of the
scenario and i've made it already an
interesting talk before we jump in and
say hi my name is this i'm from this and
today i'm here to talk to you about blah
blah blah
so have a have a story in your back
pocket it could be fun interesting
controversial whatever something that's
going to kind of get them and the trick
is i said
just
you need to be excited by it if you're
excited by it they'll be excited by it
remember the um
the lesson that what's her name miss
excel that like woman who's she
basically teaches you how to use use
excel better but somehow that's like
going viral on tick tock and why is
something as boring as excel tricks
going viral on tick tock
one of the reasons is
she like
comes out with this crazy energy she
seems really excited by this stuff and
it's just enjoyable to watch her do it
even if you're not even going to use
excel that day it's just enjoyable to
watch somebody do that and she says this
in her interview she goes content is the
transfer of emotion
i got to get myself into the emotion of
being excited about something if i ever
want you to be excited by it i have to
get myself to be fascinated by something
if i want you to be fascinated by it and
she's like i just get myself into that
state then i run to the phone click
record and i start to start to do my
thing and it's like that's actually what
it is content is the transference of
emotion and so what most people try to
do is they think about
what they're gonna say which is
intellectual that shit's words people
don't remember the words that you said
um they will remember if you had some
emotion some energy behind you and
they'll remember the vibe they remember
how you made them feel and they'll take
away just a few nuggets out of what you
said most of what you said 90 of what
you say will go in one ear and out the
other
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
and that's a thing i was i tell people
all the time i told you this when you
early on when i was maybe six months
ahead of you in terms of content you're
like i want how do i write these
articles and i was like it's not really
about what you want to teach it's about
what you want to make someone feel and
oftentimes when people give
presentations they think well i'm
talking about this like i'm talking
about like mosquitoes and how they like
cause malaria in africa and this is like
a really serious thing it's like yeah it
could be serious but you need to weave
in some stories and you need to do some
crazy and it's no different than a
comedy show or a play where you capture
attention yes you're doing it about
something important and isn't just
entertainment but you have to leave that
in there
one of my favorite tricks i've saw is
when they brought up malaria is when
steve uh bill gates or someone let uh
talked about uh malaria and mosquitoes
and he goes i want to show you why this
is an important deal and he opens up
this jar and mosquitoes fly out all over
the place he goes i'm going to tell you
about how many people die from malaria
which comes from mosquitoes just like
this and like so people like are like
you know that's showmanship and so it's
the same way with any talk you're doing
you don't have to do something that
extreme but it starts with the story it
starts with an emotion and then i would
say the last thing is you have to treat
people your audience regardless if
they're smart you kind of got to treat
them dumb meaning a lot of people what
they do is they put way too much
emphasis on the slides and in my opinion
most talks should be able to be like at
least a b level without any slide the
slide maybe makes it go from a nine to a
ten but
the slides to me um it's kind of like
when you are in when you're in a band
it's about how do i make this song great
it's not how do i make this one little
guitar solo awesome it's like no dude
the guitar solo exists to make the song
great the song doesn't exist to make
that solo awesome it's the other way
around and so it's about my my
it's about my performance and it just so
happens that this powerpoint is just one
piece of that and i need to treat people
stupid and assume that they're not going
to read the small text and it's up to me
to use my words my body language in
order to make them feel something and
the the the slides are just an extra
added effect
that's right uh all right i think that's
great there's a ton more i feel like we
could probably
like there's probably 10 more things but
really the reality is you don't need to
know all the things if you just do the
things we talked about right which is
basically
you know show up with energy
have some showmanship through either a
little magic trick or a story or
something like that and treat it like
practice because you're you're going to
need to do this 100 times before you're
you're any good at it
if you just internalize those three
you're going to be you know ahead of
head of the curve you'll be ahead of you
know 80 90 of people practice
not the game we're talking about
practice yeah we're talking about
practice
[Music]
you